Let's take a moment to look at a different
example.
Automated teller machines allow bank customers
to perform a variety of transactions: deposits,
withdrawals, transfers, etc.
Let's consider what happens when two customers
try to withdraw $50 from the same account
at the same time.
A portion of the bank's code for a withdrawal
transaction is shown in the upper right.
This code is responsible for adjusting the
account balance to reflect the amount of the
withdrawal.
Presumably the check to see if there is sufficient
funds has already happened.
What's supposed to happen?
Let's assume that the bank is using a separate
process to handle each transaction, so the
two withdrawal transactions cause two different
processes to be created, each of which will
run the Debit code.
If each of the calls to Debit run to completion
without interruption, we get the desired outcome:
the first transaction debits the account by
$50, then the second transaction does the
same.
The net result is that you and your friend
have $100 and the balance is $100 less.
So far, so good.
But what if the process for the first transaction
is interrupted just after it's read the balance?
The second process subtracts $50 from the
balance, completing that transaction.
Now the first process resumes, using the now
out-of-date balance it loaded just before
being interrupted.
The net result is that you and your friend
have $100, but the balance has only been debited
by $50.
The moral of the story is that we need to
be careful when writing code that reads and
writes shared data since other processes might
modify the data in the middle of our execution.
When, say, updating a shared memory location,
we'll need to LD the current value, modify
it, then ST the updated value.
We would like to ensure that no other processes
access the shared location between the start
of the LD and the completion of the ST.
The LD/modify/ST code sequence is what we
call a "critical section".
We need to arrange that other processes attempting
to execute the same critical section are delayed
until our execution is complete.
This constraint is called "mutual exclusion",
i.e., only one process at a time can be executing
code in the same critical section.
Once we've identified critical sections, we'll
use semaphores to guarantee they execute atomically,
i.e., that once execution of the critical
section begins, no other process will be able
to enter the critical section until the execution
is complete.
The combination of the semaphore to enforce
the mutual exclusion constraint and the critical
section of code implement what's called a
"transaction".
A transaction can perform multiple reads and
writes of shared data with the guarantee that
none of the data will be read or written by
other processes while the transaction is in
progress.
Here's the original code to Debit, which we'll
modify by adding a LOCK semaphore.
In this case, the resource controlled by the
semaphore is the right to run the code in
the critical section.
By initializing LOCK to 1, we're saying that
at most one process can execute the critical
section at a time.
A process running the Debit code WAITs on
the LOCK semaphore.
If the value of LOCK is 1, the WAIT will decrement
value of LOCK to 0 and let the process enter
the critical section.
This is called acquiring the lock.
If the value of LOCK is 0, some other process
has acquired the lock and is executing the
critical section and our execution is suspended
until the LOCK value is non-zero.
When the process completes execution of the
critical section, it releases the LOCK with
a call to SIGNAL, which will allow other processes
to enter the critical section.
If there are multiple WAITing processes, only
one will be able to acquire the lock, and
the others will still have to wait their turn.
Used in this manner, semaphores are implementing
a mutual exclusion constraint, i.e., there's
a guarantee that two executions of the critical
section cannot overlap.
Note that if multiple processes need to execute
the critical section, they may run in any
order and the only guarantee is that their
executions will not overlap.
There are some interesting engineering issues
to consider.
There's the question of the granularity of
the lock, i.e., what shared data is controlled
by the lock?
In our bank example, should there be one lock
controlling access to the balance for all
accounts?
That would mean that no one could access any
balance while a transaction was in progress.
That would mean that transactions accessing
different accounts would have to run one after
the other even though they're accessing different
data.
So one lock for all the balances would introduce
unnecessary precedence constraints, greatly
slowing the rate at which transactions could
be processed.
Since the guarantee we need is that we shouldn't
permit multiple simultaneous transactions
on the same account,
it would make more sense to have a separate
lock for each account, and change the Debit
code to acquire the account's lock before
proceeding.
That will only delay transactions that truly
overlap, an important efficiency consideration
for a large system processing many thousands
of mostly non-overlapping transactions each
second.
Of course, having per-account locks would
mean a lot of locks!
If that's a concern, we can adopt a compromise
strategy of having locks that protect groups
of accounts, e.g., accounts with same last
three digits in the account number.
That would mean we'd only need 1000 locks,
which would allow up to 1000 transactions
to happen simultaneously.
The notion of transactions on shared data
is so useful that we often use a separate
system called a database that provides the
desired functionality.
Database systems are engineered to provide
low-latency access to shared data, providing
the appropriate transactional semantics.
The design and implementation of databases
and transactions is pretty interesting.
To follow up, I recommend reading about databases
on the web.
Returning to our producer/consumer example,
we see that if multiple producers are trying
to insert characters into the buffer at the
same time,
it's possible that their execution may overlap
in a way that causes characters to be overwritten
and/or the index to be improperly incremented.
We just saw this bug in the bank example:
the producer code contains a critical section
of code that accesses the FIFO buffer and
we need to ensure that the critical section
is executed atomically.
Here we've added a third semaphore, called
LOCK, to implement the necessary mutual exclusion
constraint for the critical section of code
that inserts characters into the FIFO buffer.
With this modification, the system will now
work correctly when there are multiple producer
processes.
There's a similar issue with multiple consumers,
so we've used the same LOCK to protect the
critical section for reading from the buffer
in the RCV code.
Using the same LOCK for producers and consumers
will work, but does introduce unnecessary
precedence constraints since producers and
consumers use different indices,
i.e., IN for producers and OUT for consumers.
To solve this problem we could use two locks:
one for producers and one for consumers.
Semaphores are a pretty handy swiss army knife
when it comes to dealing with synchronization
issues.
When WAIT and SIGNAL appear in different processes,
the semaphore ensures the correct execution
timing between processes.
In our example, we used two semaphores to
ensure that consumers can't read from an empty
buffer and that producers can't write into
a full buffer.
We also used semaphores to ensure that execution
of critical sections -- in our example, updates
of the indices IN and OUT -- were guaranteed
to be atomic.
In other words, that the sequence of reads
and writes needed to increment a shared index
would not be interrupted by another process
between the initial read of the index and
the final write.